[Music]
coca-cola can do some pretty
strange things and
the ingredients inside of it might be
even
more bizarre just imagine what it's
doing
inside your body after you drink it
now let's take that one step further and
imagine
only drinking coca-cola for the rest of
your life
what effects does coca-cola have on your
body
what would this do to your teeth
and how bad would replacing water
with coke be this
is what if and here's what would happen
if you
only drank coca-cola
believe it or not someone has done
something like this before
a woman in monaco stopped drinking water
and
only drank coca-cola for 16 years
straight
did she survive doing this to her body
and what would happen if you did the
same
doctors recommend that people should
drink anywhere from
three to four liters of water a day so
instead we're going to replace that with
coca-cola
a single can of coke has 39 grams of
sugar
to get your daily fluid intake you'd
need to drink
over eight cans of coke each day
that's 312 grams of sugar
it would be like eating six chocolate
bars
for reference it's recommended that
people consume
less than 40 grams of sugar every day
so yeah this would be a lot of extra
sugar
not to mention the extra calories
your coke intake alone would be nearly
an
extra 8 000 calories a week
but that wouldn't be all the extra
calories you'd consume
this sugary drink could also cause you
to eat more as well
and with all these extra calories it
would lead to some
serious weight gain as you drank more
coke
tooth decay would also be a severe issue
each sip of coke would coat your teeth
tongue and gums for
hours after you finished your soda
unless you stuck to
an incredibly strict tooth brushing
schedule
the sugars would slowly break down your
enamel
this could eventually lead to your teeth
completely rotting
and once you're done drinking your sodas
for the day
expect to be going to the washroom a lot
the
caffeine in coca-cola is a natural
diuretic
meaning that you're going to be peeing a
lot more
but the caffeine would be the least of
your worries
one of the main ingredients you'd need
to worry about
is the high fructose corn syrup that's
because
our bodies don't metabolize it and
this could lead to a fatty liver
symptoms of a fatty liver include
fatigue
and pain in the upper right abdomen
as you continued to drink coca-cola you
would experience
even more health issues you might have
frequent fainting spells and have a
potassium deficiency
due to all the sugar caffeine and other
chemicals
you'd also experience problems with your
heart rate
but the issues won't stop there as time
goes on you'd also
have a massive risk of getting type 2
diabetes
and loads of vitamin deficiencies
and if all these issues continued and
you decided to ignore them
you could develop proteinuria which
could then lead to
kidney problems and after years of
only drinking coke you'd eventually be
600 pounds with a huge list of health
issues
you'd take your final sips of coca-cola
and then
die due to a heart attack kidney failure
or
other health-related issue but
it doesn't have to be like that remember
the woman who drank
coca-cola for 16 years she
had a lot of the same issues you had
with fainting and weight gain but
after 16 years of only drinking coke
she decided to stop and her body bounced
back to a relatively healthy state
in a short period of time so
you might be able to do this for over a
decade without experiencing any severe
repercussions but
although drinking only coke for a week a
month
or even a year wouldn't kill you
it doesn't mean you should do it another
thing you shouldn't do
jump out of an airplane without a
parachute but
luckily with our new show how to survive
we'll show you the perfect way to make
sure you get out of it alive